bonsoir bassem vous êtes donc dans la
capitale britannique plus que deux
heures avant que la grande bretagne ne
sorte de l'union européenne a
effectivement dans deux heures le sort
sera scellé et le divorce sociales et
entre londres et puis bruxelles
effectivement on est là sur parlement
squared juste à côté de westminster où
les festivités vont pas tarder à
commencer et déjà le monde et s'est
amassée ici il arrive encore de plus en
plus alors que la pelouse est noire de
monde des célébrités à des célébrations
pardon pour ce jour historique pour les
anglais ici à londres un concert doit
avoir lieu un grand écran a été installé
ici pour que les londoniens les anglais
puisse assister à ce jour de célébration
il y aura également des faisceaux
lumineux pour éviter bigben car big ben
et dans travaux donc il sonnera pas et
puis par la suite à 23 heures le rendez
vous sera donné du côté du 10 downing
street où boris johnson devra annoncer
plutôt de faire un discours un discours
à la nation pour celles et ceux brezzi
scellé ce jour historique à partir de
minuit la grande bretagne ne fera plus
partie de l'union européenne mais leur
faudra à peu près onze mois pour essayer
de dessiner de peaufiner les futures
relations entre londres et puis entre
bruxelles mais pour l'instant les gens
sa masse ici attendent le début des
festivités une nuit qui s'annonce longue
et festive pour les anglais et réunis en
masse ici pour ce jour historique ce
jour de breakbeat merci ça mais on le
voit effectivement sur ces images en
direct beaucoup de monde autour de
westminster le parlement britannique